hagamos más ejemplos de multiplicación
de matrices porque yo creo que esto se
trata de ver muchísimos ejemplos
entonces hagamos este ejemplo qué bueno
se va a ver como que es un ejemplo mucho
más complicado pero en realidad no lo es
tanto solo que ni siquiera vamos a estar
seguros nada más con ver las matrices de
si se pueden multiplicar o no y de hecho
yo creo que eso es lo primero que nos
tenemos que preguntar
así es que pues vamos a multiplicar la
matriz 3 1
2 - 2 0
a la matriz
los 13
5 25 y todos estos números me los acabo
de inventar pero bueno seguramente lo
que te estás preguntando ahorita o si no
deberías estarlo haciendo es si estas
dos matrices se pueden multiplicar ósea
porque el primer vídeo que hicimos de
matrices vimos que dos matrices se
podían sumar si la cantidad de filas y
la cantidad de columnas era la misma
porque lo que hacíamos era sumar este
término con este término y a este
término le correspondía este término
para sumarse y entonces a este término
aquí pues ya no tenemos ningún otro
número por acá entonces estas dos
matrices ni se pueden sumar ni se pueden
restar la pregunta ahora es si se pueden
multiplicar bueno pero que vimos en el
vídeo pasado estas dos matrices todavía
no lo sabemos pero vamos a ver pronto
que si en efecto si se pueden
multiplicar estas dos matrices cuando
los multiplicamos nos va a dar otra
matriz y bueno de hecho todavía no
sabemos de qué tamaño va a ser esa
matriz y siempre que se están
multiplicando dos matrices hay una forma
muy
fácil de saber qué dimensión va a tener
la matriz resultante pero para
encontrarla pues tenemos que ver este
ejercicio con lupa
así es que pues vamos a multiplicarlo ok
esta nueva matriz tiene una entrada por
aquí y como obteníamos esa entrada en el
vídeo pasado pues lo que hacíamos era
ver estas dos matrices de la matriz de
la izquierda tomar la primera fila y la
primera columna de la segunda matriz y
hacer el producto punto entre estos dos
vectores y bueno ese producto punto
definitivamente lo podemos hacer no o
sea porque este es un vector que tiene
tres entradas y este también es un
vector que tiene tres entradas y el
producto punto tal cual lo que es es
tomar esta entrada y multiplicar la por
esta ya eso sumarle la multiplicación de
esta entrada por esta entrada más esta
entrada por esta entrada y el resultado
de este producto punto es justo el
número que va aquí pero de la misma
forma podemos multiplicar esta primera
fila este vector fila
por este segundo vector columna y esto
lo que nos da es otra entrada en va a
ser la entrada que esté por aquí al
igual que podemos agarrar el segundo
vector fila este vector de aquí y hacer
el producto punto con este vector
columna para obtener otra de las
entradas va a ser la entrada que esté en
la segunda fila y primera columna y
finalmente pues podemos tomar este
vector fila y multiplicarlo por este
vector columna y obtener la última
entrada de esta matriz que está en la
última fila y última columna y así ya
habremos terminado de multiplicar y ya
sabemos exactamente cuál es su dimensión
bueno pero vamos paso por paso a ver a
ver aquí tenemos una matriz una matriz
que tiene dos files por lo cual le vamos
a poner que 12
y tiene 123 columnas 3 columnas y aquí
lo que tenemos esa otra matriz a la que
le vamos a llamar b que tiene 123 filas
entonces el 3 lo por acá y tiene dos
columnas ok bueno resulta que uno puede
multiplicar dos matrices si estos dos
números de aquí son iguales ok si en la
primera matriz el número de columnas es
exactamente igual a el número de filas
de la segunda matriz ok eso porque es
pues porque necesitamos que estos
vectores tengan la misma cantidad de
entradas para poder hacer el producto
punto entre ellos aunque aquí tenemos
tres columnas por lo cual estos vectores
van a tener tres entradas y aquí tenemos
tres filas por lo cual estos vectores
van a tener tres entradas pero bueno no
nos tenemos que quedar con dos por tres
y tres por dos o sea si tenemos
cualquier matriz por ejemplo una matriz
c
de dimensión cualquier cantidad de filas
por ejemplo n ponemos una n cuando puede
ser cualquier número y tiene por ejemplo
a cantidad de columnas entonces va a
poder multiplicar con cualquier matriz
de que tenga a cantidad de filas sin
importar qué cantidad de columnas prime
ok aquí se puede tener cualquier
cantidad de pilas y bueno estamos
diciendo que tiene a columnas y entonces
se se puede multiplicar con cualquier
matriz que tenga exactamente esa misma
cantidad a pero ahora de files ok de
filas sin importar qué cantidad de
columnas tenga que hay por aquí tener
una infinidad para una infinidad pero
muchísimas columnas siempre y cuando
tenga aquí a filas ya se va a poder
multiplicar con su ok pero bueno vamos a
multiplicar paso por paso de estas dos
matrices entonces necesitamos más
espacio
tenemos que nuestra matriz con muchísimo
espacio y en esta entrada entonces que
está en la primera y la primera columna
luego que tenemos que hacer es buscar la
primera fila de la primera matriz en
esta matriz siempre vamos a usar las
filas y la primera columna de esta
matriz que es la matriz en la que
siempre vamos a usar las columnas que
entonces son estos dos vectores y
queremos hacer el producto punto entre
este vector y este vector ok entonces
producto punto entre dos vectores ojo
este vector es un vector de uno por tres
porque tiene una fila y tres columnas y
este vector es un vector de tres por uno
porque tiene tres filas y una columna
que hay entonces si se fijan aquí
tenemos tres y tres entonces al igual
que las matrices lo podemos multiplicar
entonces producto punto tres por menos
uno
3 x menos 1 + 1 por 0 1 por 0 + 2 por 2
2 por 2 10 a todo esto es la entrada de
la primera fila y primera columna que
entonces ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar la primera fila con la
segunda columna de esta matriz y eso lo
que nos va a dar es la entrada de la
primera fila y según la columna de esta
matriz que es la matriz a por b
y entonces producto punto 3 x 3
más
1 por 5 1 por 5 + 2 por 5 2 por 5 y
listo ya terminamos vamos con la
siguiente entrada
ahora vamos a usar esta fila de esta
matriz y pues vamos a usar esta columna
de esta matriz que entonces segunda fila
primera columna esto lo que nos da es la
entrada de la matriz aprobé de la
segunda fila primera columna
ok menos dos por menos uno menos dos por
menos uno más
0 x 0
00 +
5 x 2
5 por 2 y finalmente lo único que nos
falta es multiplicar la segunda fila por
la segunda columna
y menos dos por tres menos dos por tres
más
0 x 50 x 5 + 5 x 5 + 5 x 5 y listo esas
son todas las entradas de esta matriz y
entonces resultó ser una matriz de 2 x 2
si se fijan es exactamente esta cantidad
por esta cantidad y esa no es ninguna
coincidencia porque por cada fila de la
matriz vamos a tener en la matriz a por
ve una fila entera que se obtiene
haciendo el producto punto de esa fila
con cada uno de los vectores columna
debe y pues lo mismo pasa con las
columnas que hay entonces tal cual si
queremos saber la dimensión de a por b
lo único que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar estos dos numeritos o sea
porque aquí la matriz a tiene dos filas
ok entonces la matriz a x de x solamente
va a tener dos filas
y aquí la matriz b tiene dos columnas y
una columna dos columnas por lo tanto la
matriz a por b tiene que tener dos
columnas muy bien muy bien entonces pues
vamos a sacar estos números para
terminar con este ejemplo que aquí
tenemos 3 x menos uno menos tres más uno
por cero cero más dos por dos
eso es 4 gay menos 30 más 4 ok menos 30
más 4 esto es igual a 11 y aquí tenemos
3 por 39 más uno por 55 más 2 por 5 10
95 14 10 24 24 24 y aquí tenemos menos 2
x menos 12
0 por 0 0 + 5 por 2 10
o sea 12
menos dos por tres menos 60 por 5
5 x 5 20 5 y eso es igual a 25 6 19 10 y
9 y entonces esta es la matriz a por be
ok ya veces nada más lo escribimos como
ave y es una matriz de 2 x 2 ok
2 por 2 que es el resultado de
multiplicar este 2 de la cantidad de
filas de la matriz c por este 2 que es
la cantidad de columnas de la matriz b
entonces ahorita viene la siguiente
pregunta qué es podremos multiplicar ve
por ahí o sea cambiar el orden de estas
dos matrices tú qué opinas si las
podemos multiplicar o no
y entonces ahorita nos estamos
preguntando si podemos multiplicar
- 13 05 25
x
312 menos 205
y nada más las cambia de lugar esta es
la matriz b y esta es la matriz
esta es una matriz de tres filas por dos
columnas y es una matriz de dos filas
por tres columnas gay dos filas por tres
columnas digo lo teníamos aquí pero hay
que tenerlo claro entonces tú qué dices
si se puede multiplicar o no a ver
intentémoslo
vamos a tratar de multiplicar esta fila
por esta columna y si se puede
multiplicar osea podemos hacer el
producto punto entre estos dos vectores
y lo que nos queda es
- uno por tres más tres por menos 23 por
menos 2 gay y eso está en la primera
fila y primera columna de nuestra nueva
matriz haber y de acuerdo a lo que
habíamos dicho antes estos dos numeritos
si son iguales por lo cual si se pueden
multiplicar estas matrices y qué
dimensión va a tener la nueva matriz
pues va a tener una dimensión de tres
por tres que ésta va a ser una matriz de
tres por tres porque aquí tenemos tres
filas
entonces la matriz b ahora va a tener
tres filas por acá y la matriz a tiene
tres columnas
por lo cual la matriz de ahora va a
tener tres columnas que íbamos a seguir
multiplicando ahora vamos a multiplicar
la primera fila por la segunda columna
sea menos 1 por 1 eso es menos 1
menos uno más tres por cero y eso es
cero o sea nos va a quedar nada más el
menos uno entonces ahora vamos con esta
última entrada que está en la primera
fila y tercera columna o sea que vamos a
hacer el producto punto de la primera
fila con la tercera columna entonces nos
queda menos uno por dos menos uno por
dos más tres por cinco
es por 5 haber aquí tenemos menos tres
más tres por menos 23 por menos 2 es
menos 6 y aquí tenemos un menos 3 o sea
que esto nos queda menos 9 aquí ya
tenemos menos uno menos
y de aquí tenemos menos 1 por 2 o sea
menos 2 + 3 por 5 3 por 515 menos 2 13
y ahora vamos con la segunda fila
segunda fila producto punto con primera
columna nos va a dar la entrada de la
segunda fila primera columna de nuestra
matriz b por a y es 0 por 3 0 más 5 por
menos 2 eso es menos 10 menos 10
vamos con la segunda fila segunda
columna segunda fila segunda columna 0
por 1 0
nada 5 por 0 0 0 y finalmente según api
la tercera columna 0 por 2 0 15 por 5 20
5 y ahora tercera fila primera columna 2
por 36 más 5 por menos 2 eso es menos 10
sea 6 menos 10 menos 4 tercera y la
segunda columna 2 por 12 5 por 0 0 o sea
y finalmente tercera fila tercera
columna 2 por 2 4 más 5 por 5 25 25 4
eso es 20 9 ok entonces de x a es una
matriz de 3 por 3 el 3 lo obtuvimos de
la cantidad de filas que tiene la matriz
b y el segundo 3 lo obtuvimos de la
cantidad de columnas que tiene la matriz
a entonces ve por a es una matriz mucho
más grande que la matriz a por b y ahora
vamos a borrarlo todo para hacer otro
ejemplo
bueno vamos a ver si podemos multiplicar
es nuestra matriz que tiene dimensiones
tiene una sola fila y tiene dos columnas
ok y queremos ver si las podemos
multiplicar por la matriz b
la matriz de y bueno no sé digamos que
la matriz b es pues no sé pongámosle 1 2
456 aunque entonces la matriz b es una
matriz de que tiene 123 filas tres filas
y tiene dos columnas dos columnas aunque
entonces aquí la pregunta es si podemos
multiplicar la matriz a por la matriz b
ok entonces para obtener la primera
entrada lo que hacemos es multiplicar
esta fila por esta columna ok entonces
multiplicamos 2 por 1 2 por 1 + 1 por 2
1 por 2 y ahora ahora no tenemos más que
hacer con este 3 o 6 t3 se queda fuera
de esta fila entonces aquí pues ya no
sabemos qué hacer no o sea o sea no
podemos hacer el producto punto entre
estos dos vectores aunque ya es algo que
pudimos haber visto desde el principio
lo único que teníamos que hacer era
fijarnos en las dimensiones de estas dos
matrices aunque aquí nosotros teníamos
que ver que este 2 que es la cantidad de
columnas de la matriz de la izquierda
fuera igual a este 3 que es la cantidad
de filas de la matriz b de la segunda
matriz y no son iguales entonces estas
dos matrices no se pueden multiplicar y
bueno de esta matriz
este 21 si esta es una matriz que además
es su propio vector fila o sea los
vectores también son matrices bueno te
veo en el próximo vídeo